you thought you knew but you didn't
actually know
yeah
all right we're getting into all right
the next match this is
yeah this is going to be uh rocks
infested playing fakumram against uh
it's jdcr's armor king as predicted
uh this is a match we're going to have
in the winners final this is going to be
a
best of five match so first of three
gonna have a little bit of a long set
here
top three guaranteed for both players
already but who is going to be moving on
to the grand finals
will be [ __ ] wrong we'll be arma king
infested trying to make a name for
himself already taking out a ton of
killers in the tournament took our knee
took out john ding
oh my goodness look at the space from
jcr though
hey hey
more than half off what's the mix up
shins
wow
oh
unblockable tech catch again too okay
yes fight we've seen jdcr do that a
couple times spear
yeah he tried to get him duck again
yeah oh okay and the punishment
yeah
that's not that much damage i think he's
willing to take those
chopping away low infested oh ducking
there
yeah you know waiting this is what
chanel did to jim's yard first right
like that extended duck yeah yeah you do
something remember i'm a ducker and then
knocked up later right
yeah
yeah look at the investment look at the
patience from both yeah yeah yeah
yeah and this was kind of expected you
know just oh wow
that's probably why i've described the
players before we started here yeah
time though gonna be a factor in jcr a
little bit behind here
wow infested plane it's so well the
multi-throat is coming up oh it's rage
damage boost as well
oh no you're not enough dude
you have the rage boost
maybe this is the damage problem that
he's been talking about maybe oh running
three no he's not about combo damage oh
the combo damage okay
oh
counter and get up
yeah dunk them
stunner
and life are still very close here
got him yeah step on it
oh
invest is still here
it's possible oh
this chaser just stops them out of his
uh the startup frames fight
there's the lows now no more spears yeah
yep
trying the bit off it doesn't get ducked
again with jd with the low parry
nice call out here gonna get some good
positioning
oh okay blocks the low again one point
with those punishes invested
yeah
jcr ah a little slippery left ties it up
in rounds
in the final round of this first game
great adaptation by investing here so
far you know jd really didn't control it
first but investors brought it all the
way back
now you can see he's much more
comfortable in his offense
good block
yeah he's been blocking those
oh
look at the pressure
and he wants to play right in his face
and dark are you kidding me but he
dropped the combo
yes and jdcr oh oh my god he's [ __ ]
wrong still got a little bit left it's
so dangerous
he wanted the calendar for the win
man the cajones on this man all right
yeah if james started don't like a
downford one in that situation that
could have been the whole game for
infested but instead uh jd was a low
kick that time
uh and it works out get some game uh but
that first game could have gone either
way right that was down to the wire
i had a big big call out there from
infested it wasn't necessarily a bad
idea either i think you know
specifically against jdcr uh pretty good
call out actually but doesn't work out
for him
yeah if you're that down in that
situation uh yeah you might might as
well go for it uh here and there but
yeah i mean i think um this is a long uh
set right so
um i mean the the first round or the
first match here is going to look
different from the ones later on of
course we've been doing best of threes
uh and uh we're gonna see this uh this
will play unfold i think uh as as the
games go on and um yeah i feel like
infested is one of those players where
um
you know with his he's a rock sponsored
player right and his teammates are uh
chanel and me who have this very very
patient-paced playstyle that um i think
works really well uh and he
really tests the patience of his
opponents but i feel like jdcr is
somebody who
uh can definitely deal with that
yeah the thing about having a really
patient playstyle in this game though is
that you have to be very strong
defensively uh because there's a lot of
strong offensive options game that can
really screw you up if you're trying to
play super defensive in fact we saw that
working against infested earlier in his
cbm match right when you try to be super
defensive to close out when he was about
to win uh so not easy to do at all
especially not at this level of
competition where their offensive
strategy is going to be so effective
against you too uh so let's see what
happened to game two
you're on super stage and look at the
spacing for the while standing three
there that was nuts
that's beautiful oh
i can't believe he did that
yeah yeah that was that was so clean
oh wait wait
break the crap
and yeah he's looking great
yeah
much more aggressive than the first game
very aggressive yeah we're just talking
about his defensive style but look at
this
pressing forward
oh all the hits hit me running three
and this is beat down all right jd with
the block here
yeah wow
nicely done yep
hey
okay
running away with this round but
invested in rage
oh scabs here
[Music]
good block delayed hot cake putty yeah
yo
i can't do those
all right still going low and faster
oh what a beautiful whip punish there
great spacing
this small stage is gonna jdcr
very close to the wall here he rolls
forward
break it oh god oh
oh
dcr does not they want to deal with that
guard break mix-ups
he's got to move or hit a button or
something get out yeah he moved yeah
both players keeping this very slow yo
compact yo they're just dabbing
literally
sometimes
yeah
oh man
right when he does timing on that yeah
is going to put
great positioning for it okay
wow
[Music]
all right no duct tape
[Music]
yeah he was behind two zero rounds in
that game right he turned it all around
there nicely done jdcr you know
historically i've never really been a
big fan of jd's army i've told him this
something i'd like to talk to trashman
is back he knows this but i'm impressed
today i'm impressed today this is this
is very fun to watch this arma king is
really really sick right now uh and
defensively all the the decisions he's
made and the punishes have been on point
uh even the one delay hopkins punished
he had at the end of the round when you
don't even need a delayed hopkins you
don't have to do that uh like
you don't have to do that you just do
while standing for no delayed hopkins
the punish i do on this you know when i
block it sent a message just really well
played super big message and two to zero
now against the focus
now you mentioned infested also has
potentially a negan to bring out uh
obviously we know jdtr has that pocket
[ __ ] wrong he's won big terms before
with it so he has a lot of focus
experience and it's really showing here
uh there's a lot of like mix-ups that
[ __ ] one throws at you that jd is not
even being phased by it's like yeah if
it's the higher i'm gonna duck it's the
mid i'm gonna block it uh you know he
looks like he's had a lot of experience
against this so
i'm curious here if he's actually going
to try to switch characters because the
[ __ ] rom yeah as good as it looked at
the beginning of the second game doesn't
look like it's gonna be able to get it
done to me
you know
yeah be interesting to see what invested
does he is down too this is a very tough
situation he's sticking uh with the
fakumuram here uh
yeah same stage
yeah
yeah this is such an uphill battle right
um being down 2-0 like this but uh
infested you know
uh we'll see what he has
if you can make it turn around
and [ __ ] with the wrong game
yeah
yeah [ __ ] mom can definitely do it
right
yeah the thing is you just know that
defensively it's going to be difficult
against you can't get away with
everything you get away with against
everyone else because jd defense against
character is so much better than
everyone else has been look at that he
committed that duck he's like oh
this is the range you want to do it
oh dude that jab was sick oh my god that
jab
back one that was clean though
yeah
oh
yeah
oh but you know the best it does have to
likely hero it's pretty cool oh never
mind
kisses that wall yes
yes oh
looking so strong right now impenetrable
defense
[Music]
oh my gosh
wow this is everything
look at yo he's standing there
i mean that's not the
in general right they're both in each
other's face
yeah oh perfect spacing punish there
jd's are looking so dominant
wow
this is round yeah this is looking like
it's going to be a 3-0 infested
need to make something happen here
and he was blocking a lot of those
not anymore
yeah what was that that looks like a
input
oh
yeah big accidental jump but here comes
the combo from jd here
ball carry bing bang boom
what's the mix-up
oh trade here getting started enraged
okay
oh i guess that grabbing
oh he's still alive
last chance infested stay on the side of
the bracket here get out of here
moving on to the grand finals with the
arm king 3-0 infested it's like hey kid
you've had a good run john ding
knee
cherry berry mango
not jdcr i'm staying off the list right
now
right
yeah i'm staying off